I remember trying to start at night okay
so yeah the first three episodes
very it's hard it's great oh all right
will you email me that to remind me yes
if you asked him my mom got me onto it
I'm I can't stop watching that series
and then it's one of those right oh
you're just gonna get through the first
that's the story they talk about that
show they're like one of the best shows
ever made I'm like I watch two episodes
and I could not sit through it and
they're like you just have to get
through like three or four and then it's
brilliant and I'm like oh Lord kind of
like White Lotus
I don't know and I kept watching and
watching and then at the end it got
better yeah but I was like you know I
don't want to watch five episodes I
don't care about